- [Zach] Yeah, good morning, everybody.
Still morning?
Good afternoon, I guess.
Today, we're here to talk
about automating certificate management
with exportable public certificates.
I'm Zach Miller, I'm a
principal security SA.
I cover our cryptography services
and Pravin, you wanna introduce yourself?
- [Pravin] Hi, everybody,
my name is Pravin Nair.
I'm a security specialist at
AWS focused on data protection
and privacy.
I'm hoping everybody at the
end are able to hear me fine.
If not, I'm okay to speak up a little bit.
I sometimes speak on a lower
note, so please be frank enough
to let me know if I'm
speaking on a lower note.
Thank you.
So that's my introduction.
I'll pass it on to Zach.
- [Zach] Awesome, yeah, so like I said,
today we're gonna talk about
exportable certificates
with a service called
AWS Certificate Manager.
You may be familiar with this launch,
but the basic idea is that in
the past we had certificates
that you could issue
from public certificates,
I should say, that you should issue,
you could issue from ACM
and you could assign those,
or bind those to resources
that were integrated with ACM.
So you could assign it
to a load balancer,
application load balancer,
or an API gateway or CloudFront.
And customers said, "Hey,
I have these use cases
where I have a firewall that
runs in my data center
or runs on EC2 and AWS,
and these aren't things
that are integrated with ACM
and I still wanna get public
certificates to those devices.
And so that's why we
built this new feature
where you're able to
export the private key
of public certificates.
And so I'll talk a little bit about what
that feature is and in a
little bit more detail,
we'll go through some of the challenges
that we see customers face when it comes
to certificate management in general.
And in particular, again, with these kind
of non-integrated services or devices,
how you can handle managed renewal,
or automated renewal.
And Pravin has some pretty cool code
and demo that he's gonna show
that we built that shows you
how to kind of automate
some of these renewals.
So we'll talk about public certificates,
I'll talk about the challenges
with installing them
and a lot of you are
probably already familiar
with some of these challenges.
We'll go into a kind of a
deep dive of the architecture
and the code and then Pravin will show
a demo of how it works.
And do feel free to raise your hand,
ask questions, interrupt us.
That's totally fine, we
wanna keep it interactive.
So if you do have questions
throughout, let us know.
Happy to answer those.
Okay, so like I mentioned before,
we have this service
AWS Certificate Manager.
It is used to issue both public
and private certificates.
And it has this nice feature
called Managed Renewal
where again, with things like ALB,
about 60 days before the
certificate is about to expire,
ACM will issue a new certificate.
It will bind that certificate
to the same resource,
say like in the ALB or API gateway.
And it'll handle that renewal for you.
And there's kind of two
mechanisms for domain validation.
There's email validation
and DNS name validation.
We highly, highly recommend
you use DNS name validation,
because it allows you
to have that no touch,
not think about certificate
renewal experience.
Where email validation,
still pretty simple,
but you have to click a link in an email
and many times customers
will be on vacation,
or that person's left
the company or whatever,
whatever the reason is, that
email somehow gets missed,
that link doesn't get clicked.
You could face an outage or
something of that nature.
And we don't want that.
So highly, highly recommend
you use DNS name validation,
'cause it just means you
have to create a DNS record,
a CNM record that basically says,
"Hey, yeah, I own this domain."
And so again, like what we saw
with customers is they were like,
"I love the managed experience
of assigning this certificate
to an ALB and renewal.
I don't have to think about certificates."
That's great, but I have EC2
instances where I run nginx
and terminate TLS there
and I have a, maybe Palo
Alto next-gen firewall
that I use on-prem and I
need a certificate for that.
So how do I do that?
And they want to consolidate down
to one certificate provider.
And so we built this feature called
Exportable Public Certificates.
And another nice feature of it
too is you have the same type
of access control you're
used to with IAM, of course,
and it's integrated with AWS CloudTrail
and Amazon CloudWatch, so
you get nice observability on
how your certificates are used
and kind of all the
details around rotation
and things like that.
And so when we're talking
about the use cases for this,
I called out quite a few of them already,
but you might have servers,
or where you're terminating
TLS on another cloud provider
and a lot of our
customers are multi-cloud,
you might have on-premise systems
that you wanna get these certificates to.
Firewalls is a really big
use case we hear about
and just other services
that aren't integrated with ACM.
Like EC2 instances, EKS and
just containers in general.
You wanna get public certificates
to terminate TLS on those devices.
You need to be able to
export the private key,
'cause you need that private
key to actually terminate TLS.
I wanna talk a little
bit about pricing too.
This has been a driver for
customers to reduce their costs,
because as some of you know,
public surveys can be pretty expensive.
And so we've priced it, I think,
very competitively
where you have each FQDN
is $15
for each cert,
and you only pay that once
when you export the cert.
So you may know already that
when you request a public certificate
and assign it to an
integrated service like ALB,
there's no charge.
No charge, it's a free certificate.
That is still true, you only pay
for the certificate when
you export it the first time
and then never again until it's renewed.
So it's not like you're paying
for it per month or anything like that.
You pay for it the
first time you export it
and then the next time it's renewed,
you'll pay again after you export.
So again, $15
per FQDN.
So if you have, one.example.com
and two.example.com, that would be $30.
Go ahead, yeah.
- [Crowd Member 1] Is it the same
if you had multiple SANs to assert?
- [Zach] Yes, good question, exactly.
So say you had the regular common name
and then you had two SANs,
that would be three FQDN,
so $45.
Yep.
Hmm?
- [Crowd Member 1] Is that a
one time fee for the export,
or every time?
- [Zach] One time fee for the export.
So you can export that
as many times as you like after that.
Yeah, absolutely.
Just the one time fee
and then the next time that
certificate is renewed,
like the next year, it's
technically a new certificate.
So you would pay that again.
But yeah, so you can continue to export
that certificate as
many times as you need.
- [Crowd Member 1] Is it billed
at the time of generation?
Like is it flagged as exportable,
and perhaps because it's flagged
as exportable, it's billed?
Or even if I were to never export it.
- [Zach] No, that's a good question.
So I'll repeat the question
just so people hear it.
So the question is when
you create the certificate,
if you mark it as exportable
are you billed then,
no, you are only billed
the minute you export it.
So when you call the
export certificate API
and you get that private key,
that's when you'll be billed.
- [Crowd Member 1] So then in
theory we can flag everything,
it's exportable, but as long
as nobody actually goes in
and actually exports it, then?
- [Zach] Yes.
That is true.
The only thing I would say there is
a bunch of customers when
we talk to them said,
"I don't want my developers to
just export any certificate."
And so you have to market it
as exportable when you create,
or request a certificate.
So if you originally request a certificate
and you say, "This is not exportable."
You will never be able to change that.
I mean, you could
reissue a new certificate
for the same domain, but you won't be able
to then change it later.
And so my only kind of word of
caution there is if you have
that use case where you're like,
some customers view it
as a security feature
that you cannot export that private key.
And so I wouldn't necessarily
advise putting everything
exportable unless you
have a use case for it.
But yes, you could definitely do that.
- [Crowd Member 1] Strictly
from the building costs.
- [Zach] Sure, yeah.
Absolutely, sure.
- [Crowd Member 2] Maybe I'm
being ahead of myself here,
but if I'm wanted to test the
life cycle of a certificate,
including exporting, then
I only want the certificate
to be a couple of days at the most.
But I have to basically pay
for a whole year, don't I?
- [Zach] Yeah, effectively, yeah, yeah.
There's no, it's not prorated in that way.
Yeah, unfortunately, yeah.
- [Crowd Member 2] There's no way
to get a short-lived
certificate currently?
So there is, okay, so
there's two services.
There's AWS Certificate Manager,
it issues public certs and private certs.
There is AWS Private CA,
which we're not gonna talk
about too much in this session,
but you can absolutely,
there's a short-lived
certificate mode for that.
And those certificates are
priced at a lower price
per certificate and they
only live up to seven days.
So that would be like for customers that,
"Hey, I have a Kubernetes workload,
I rebuild my pods every single day.
I don't need a cert that lives a year.
I need a cert that lives a day
and I don't want to pay
for a cert for a year."
So you can do that with private certs.
With ACM, at least today,
the certificate template is kind
of set in stone and it's
a three, what is it, 365?
- [Pravin] Yeah, 13 months.
- [Zach] Yeah, 13 months, sorry.
That's right, 13 months.
It's a 13 month certificate.
So you can't change that
validity period today,
I can't say a whole lot more,
but we're thinking about
other ways to reduce that,
because as you may know, the
cab forum has made some changes
where they're gonna reduce
the certificate lifetime.
So we will of course adjust
our service to deal with that.
- [Crowd Member 1] And pricing,
what about the pricing?
Is it every 30 days?
- [Zach] That is also
a very good question.
So I can't say exactly the, here,
if you talk to me in the hallway after,
I can probably give some more detail,
but yes, we will be addressing that,
there will be a pricing
change that will reflect
the shorter renewal periods.
Yeah, absolutely.
- [Crowd Member 3] Because
the first drop is here March,
or April, so 200 days?
- [Zach] Yes, yeah.
I can't say too much,
but yes, if we talk, come
find me after the hallway,
we'll talk in more detail,
but yes, we're absolutely
planning for those changes
and the pricing will reflect that
and customers should not be
paying more based on that.
- [Crowd Member 2] So prior to the export
of the private key,
it's in HSM?
- [Zach] Well, yes, so, okay,
so the way that ACM works
basically is when you create
a certificate in ACM, we generate
a private key and we wrap,
or encrypt that private key
with a KMS key in your account.
So there's a KMS key
called the AWS Managed Key.
It has an alias that says
this would be aws/acm.
And that key is actually used
to protect the private
key in your account.
And that KMS key is protected
by FIPS 140-3 level three validated HSM.
- [Crowd Member 2] So
the minute it's exported,
it's no longer HSM, it's
just no longer HSM, right?
- [Zach] That's right.
When you export the private key,
Pravin will show this, but
it is exported encrypted.
You basically set a
passphrase when you export it,
but yeah, it will no longer be,
it will be exported from the service.
So it wouldn't be protected by an HSM.
And so Pravin will get
into this a little bit on
how we recommend securing
those private keys.
But yes, you're right,
once you export that key,
that's kind of what I
was alluding to earlier
with the security consideration,
why you probably don't wanna mark all
of your searches exportable right away,
just because that does
allow application teams
to export that private
key if they want to.
And you probably wanna make sure
there's actually a real use case for that
to limit risk of key compromise.
Good questions.
Okay.
Yeah, so the only other thing
I think I didn't cover is
the wildcard certificates.
So wildcard certificates
are priced a little bit
differently at $149.
So,
okay.
Probably a lot of you,
well, yeah, go ahead.
- [Crowd Member 4] So if I had wildcards
and I have SANs attached to that,
will I be charged 149 firsthand?
- [Zach] Sorry, say that one more time.
- [Crowd Member 1] So I do
have (speaks in the distance).
- [Zach] Yeah, so say you had three SANs
and then the regular common
name, that would be four FQDN,
so it'd be four times 15.
- [Crowd Member 4] Or
four times three 15s.
- [Zach] No, no, 'cause
the wildcard certificates,
there's no,
basically the wildcard,
you wouldn't have SAN,
you wouldn't be charged
for the SAN in that way,
it's the flat $140, 140.
Yeah, yeah, so.
- To be sure,
multiple wildcard names
on top of our certs?
- [Zach] No, you cannot do that.
So you could only protect
the one sub-domain with,
so like food.example.com, bar.example.com,
but not food.bar.example.com.
(crowd member 4 speaks in the distance)
Yeah, that's right.
So let me ask, so who here
deals with certificates daily,
or at least a lot?
You know, probably, okay,
probably everyone's familiar.
Anyone have the experience
of creating Outlook calendar
reminders to renew your certificates?
Oh yeah, yeah, I've been
there, I've been there too.
So I think that's the
obvious example of some
of the challenges.
You have things I talked about before,
like if you have manual processes,
you have a human being that
has to go manually type in
that cert and put it into a key store
and it's kind of all this
whole manual process.
Obviously there's a lot of room for error,
certs and TLS tend to
be a little bit finicky,
as probably everyone knows.
And so, we do see these
challenges from customers
and that's why we originally built ACM
and then of course why
we built this feature
to export the private key.
And so aside from even
just those manual installation challenges,
you have things like all
these different environments.
You have nginx running on EC2,
you have your different
load balancers and proxies
and all these things where you might need
to put a certificate
and there's not a super
consistent way always
to get the certificates where
they need to go, basically.
And then you have things like renewal gaps
where you have an expired
certificate that leads
to some type of outage
and TLS stacks broken
and you're not able,
your users aren't able
to access your service.
And so those are the
things we wanna avoid.
We want to get to a place eventually
where customers never have
to think about certificates.
It's just kind of an automated
thing where they get renewed,
they get placed where they need to go.
And that's kind of what this solution
that Pravin is gonna
show, is attempting to do.
And so when we look at
what we wanted to kind
of the requirements we were looking to
achieve when we built this,
we wanted to look at things
like event-driven architecture.
Make sure that you have the ability
to manually renew if you need to,
but we really want it to be automated.
We want it to be based on
those CloudWatch alerts
and EventBridge alerts
that are published when
a certificate's about to expire.
And so you'll see when
Pravin shows the demo
that there's kind of two ways to do it.
You can manually renew
or you can have a lambda,
or EventBridge rule
that's basically listening
for these events that say,
"Hey, this certificate's about to expire.
You need to trigger a lambda."
And you'll see the details of everything,
but you need to actually export that cert
and place it where it needs to go.
We also wanted to make sure of course,
that that private key is secured.
When you do export the cert,
just like every other AWS API,
it happens over HTTPS.
So it is encrypted in transit,
but you also specify a passphrase
and that cert will be
encrypted with the passphrase.
And in our case we store that
passphrase in Secrets Manager
for more secure storage.
Yeah.
And so when we get into
these two types of workflows,
like I talked about, we have
the on-demand kind of method,
which would be,
"Hey, I'm going to
manually renew this cert."
Maybe it's some type of compromise.
Maybe you just have a
requirement where you need
to manually renew it
earlier than you expected.
And so you're able to trigger an API
and just kind of manually renew that cert.
Or I shouldn't say manually,
but manually trigger
the automation I guess is more accurate.
And then you also have, like I mentioned,
automated certificate renewal
where EventBridge is doing
that trigger and we're listening for that
and we'll kind of in an automated way,
export that cert, put
it where it needs to go.
Any other questions before
we talk about architecture?
Oh, oh yeah.
- [Crowd Member 1] Is support centralized
on a single domain in
an organization for IAM?
- [Zach] Single domain for?
(crowd member 1 speaks in the distance)
- [Zach] Yeah, yeah.
So yes, so you can, when
you export that key,
you could definitely put it on
a device in another account.
Does our solution
support that?
- Yeah, I think it does.
- [Zach] Yeah.
Do you wanna talk about that?
- [Pravin] So what's the question?
- [Crowd Member 1] Automation
where (speaks in the distance)
- [Zach] Sorry, can you repeat that?
It's hard to hear.
- [Crowd Member 1] Speaking
more like automation.
I don't wanna have to really
deal with the expertise.
- Oh, I see.
- Wanna know if you can
do it across accounts.
- [Pravin] Yes, you can do that
and I'm gonna talk about that.
- [Zach] Yeah, yeah, we'll
get into that in a second.
Go ahead.
(crowd member 1 speaks in the distance)
So we use domain validation, so you need
to create a CNAME record
that proves you own
that domain when you request a cert,
regardless of whether
it's wildcard or not.
Yeah, and you could also
use email validation.
Again, it's not really
something we recommend,
but yeah, either way,
typically if you use Route 53
for DNS, ACM will actually go
and create that record on it's own.
Like you don't need to,
kinda a one-click button,
or it'll do it on own.
Whereas you may need to
update your DNS records manual
if you have another provider.
But yeah, as long as
that CNM record is there,
that proves you own that domain,
we'll validate it and issue the cert.
Any other, oh yeah.
- [Crowd Member 2] Okay.
You did mention that you
can do the one-click update,
but there's also a lot of times where ACM
and your Route 53 zone
are in different accounts
that causes problems.
Have you guys thought of
any solutions about allowing
RAM shares for ACM so
that it can be shared
across multiple accounts
to make a lot of that easier?
- [Zach] Yeah, that's a good
question and that is something
that customers have challenges with.
So the question was about,
maybe I have Route 53 zones
in a different account
that I'm issuing the certificate
and it doesn't have that same kind
of integrated seamless workflow
around creating the CNAME record.
Maybe let's talk in the
hallway in more detail after.
But yes, that is something we're aware of.
What I often see customers
do in that case is,
as you probably know when
you issue the certificate,
it publishes in the
EventBridge notification there,
there's this basically the
CNAME information you need
and oftentimes customers will have
to kind of create automation
on their own to grab
that record, put it in some
kind of central repository,
or feed it into another account
and create the record through automation.
It's like assume we're
rolling in the other account
and do it.
So there are ways customers
do it today that are
workarounds that you have to build.
We're looking at ways to
make that experience easier,
but it's not something I
can talk about right now.
But yeah, that's a good question.
Okay.
Oh yeah, sorry, go ahead.
- [Crowd Member 5] You
mentioned that the price might
(speaks in the distance)
- [Zach] Sorry, you said,
you gotta speak-
- On contract.
So just curious to understand,
does it mean before we
continue the On-prem instances-
- [Zach] Yes, so Pravin will
go into that a little bit on
how we do that but
yeah, so when you export
that private key, I mean
obviously you can put it wherever
you would like.
What Pravin is gonna talk about is
how the sample code we've written
helps you actually install
that certificate securely on, for example,
like an on-premise server.
So he'll get into that.
So I'm not gonna get too into it,
'cause he'll get deep into
that and show that in practice.
But yes, you can absolutely do that
for on-premise servers as well.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think I'll pass over to Pravin.
He's gonna talk about the architecture
and then he'll kind of do
a deep dive into the code
and the demo.
- [Pravin] Yeah, so
I'll go over the architecture diagram.
So this is our,
there are two workflows to this solution.
This is the first workflow,
this is on-demand certificate.
What it requires is you already
have a certificate issued
with ACM with DNS
validated and it is issued,
once you have the certificate,
you need to have the
ARN of the certificate.
What we're gonna do is we
are gonna have a API gateway,
which will take an API,
we have an API template
which we will share.
It is there on the sample code as well.
You pass the certificate ARN
and certificate name, details
and what this solution actually
does is it actually goes
and installs the
certificate on EC2 instances
and it can do this at scale.
So if you have multiple EC2 instances,
you can install it on more
than one EC2 instances as well,
because it's tag-based.
So what it's doing is using tags
to identify which EC2 instance
it needs to go and install
and what we are using internally
is actually systems manager.
How many of you here are familiar
with system manager?
Okay, so for the folks
who are not familiar
with systems manager in AWS,
it's basically a management
solution that people use
to manage their fleet of EC2 instances.
If you have multiple EC2
instance, you want to patch them,
you want to run ad hoc
queries, commands on them.
You could do that with systems manager.
So it has a concept called
as automation document.
You can write your custom commands,
or scripts in that automation document
and you can run them at scale
across multiple EC2 instances.
So there's one gentleman
asking about on-prem.
So systems manager can also
manage servers on-prem.
So you could actually manage
some of your EC2 instances
through, so some of your on-prem servers
through systems manager
and run the commands
and install the certificates
on-prem as well.
Going back to our solution,
what we are trying
to do is it's,
the first instance you call the API,
you tell what EC2
instances you need to apply
the certificates on.
You give the name of the certificate
and you give the ARN of the certificate.
That's gonna trigger a step function.
A step function has
three lambda functions.
The first lambda function
is to actually go
and export the certificate from ACM.
Now, for exporting a certificate from ACM,
you need to pass a passphrase,
which means the passphrase
actually encrypts the private key
as it comes out of ACM, like I said.
Like Zach was talking about inside ACM,
the private key is encrypted by KMS.
Once you bring it out it's not encrypted.
So we give you an
encryption with a passphrase
so it's encrypted and once it comes out.
What we have done in this
automation is you don't have
to create or do anything
with the passphrase.
We will generate a dynamic passphrase,
which even the user is not aware about.
We're going to take that passphrase
and we're gonna store
it in Secrets Manager.
All right.
And then we are gonna take the private key
and the public key and
we're gonna pass it on
to the second Lambda function.
And we're also, if you see there,
there is a DynamoDB table out there,
what that DynamoDB table does
is it actually stores the metadata
about where the certificate
is being installed.
A lot of times when you export
certificates out, people,
or customers tend to forget
where that certificate's gone.
I do not know where the
certificate is right now.
So what that DynamoDB table
does is it stores exactly
the tags where the EC2 instances,
which EC2 instances, those are installed.
It has the ARN, it has
also got the expiry date
and everything inside that.
So if anytime you want to go
and check, hey, how many
certificates have exported,
where it is, what EC2
instances it installed,
all that is there in the DynamoDB table.
Once we have that,
we pass the certificate details
like private key, public key
to the systems manager automation dock.
Now, this example installs
it on a Linux machine,
which is a normal Amazon Linux machine.
It goes into the cert
folders and installs it.
You could modify the
automation document to do it,
do an installation,
clean installation on an nginx server,
or any custom application
that you might have.
It's just a bunch of commands
that you have to run,
you can do it.
You can do it for Windows as well,
if you have an IIS server that you want
to update the certificate to,
that's just another automation document.
If you want to move
that certificate outside
to another cloud provider,
you could do that too,
but you may not be using
systems manager at that point,
you might have to use
a different solution.
So I'm kind of looking at trying
to move this certificate
into an external vault,
or somewhere from where
it can be integrated
by other cloud providers as well.
But that's an extension I'm working,
which I'll be working on for the next year
and I'll have a solution on
the samples updated with that.
But for now it does it on EC2 instances
and it uses systems manager
and if you are planning to use any of this
and you have a specific
application or anything,
absolutely feel free to reach out.
I'm happy to help out if you
are looking for any assistance,
or direction around how
the code should look like.
- [Zach] It is also open
source as well on GitHub.
So you know, feel free
to contribute as well.
- [Pravin] Yeah and it's a,
so yeah it's a GitHub resource,
if you have questions you can do
and I'm gonna share the link
where it is available in
the, it's in AWS samples.
So one of the key things of
exportable certificate is
that once the certificate is exported,
it's customers,
it becomes, we work on
shared responsibility model.
Once you export the certificate,
it's customer's responsibility
to secure that private key.
So like I talked about, we did two things
to make sure your private key is secured.
So first one is, like I said,
we generate the passphrase
for you and we store that passphrase
inside a Secret Manager
in the Secret Manager
and then we also tag the Secret Manager,
that secret, same as the
EC2 instances instances.
And what we are doing is
actually we are doing ABAC,
which is attribute-based access control,
which means the EC2 instance
tag, EC2 instance profile tag,
and this secret tag needs to
match for the EC2 instance
to get the passphrase and
decrypt the private key
and use it in the application.
So it's not like I put a secret somewhere
and any EC2 instance can
go and access that secret.
It's attribute-based to
only specific EC2 instances
for where the certificate is installed.
Only they can go and access
that secret to encrypt,
or decrypt the private key for their use.
So those are the two key things
that we give with this solution.
Any questions on this until now?
All right, yep.
- [Crowd Member 2] So it would not go
auto-discover existence of
the ACM we have installed,
for example, I have my
certificates there, once again,
where we do all, would it
auto-discover or do I need to do
it for setup?
- [Pravin] No, so it cannot go
and auto-discover certificates.
It's only if you issue
the certificates to ACM
and you want to export it
and install it outside,
that's the part it is going to automate
and it's going to do a
second part of the solution,
which is the renewal of the certificate.
So what we have is we
have an EventBridge rule
created with the cloud formation.
What it does is looks for the
event when the certificate,
the public certificate is renewed.
So your public certificate
which is exportable.
They are basically renewed
60 days before the expiry.
So before the certificate,
so 60 days before, when
the certificate is renewed
and issued, it'll trigger
off a job which will be
where we call our lambda function.
And that lambda function actually
takes the certificate ARN,
it's able to look up based on the ARN,
whether that certificate was exported
and installed on an EC2 instance.
If it is, then it is going
to take the relevant
details from the database
and it is going to
trigger the step function.
And then the process is same,
it's going to export the
new renewed certificate,
it's going to create a passphrase for it,
it's gonna update the passwords
in the Secrets Manager
and it's gonna go and install
those certificates exactly
where it installed last time,
running the same scripts.
So what this means is you do
not have to worry about renewal
of the certificate even
on your EC2 instances.
This solution is going to
automatically identify that and go
and install it on your EC2 instances.
And obviously we have logging
and everything enabled.
So if there is any issues or anything,
you will be able to go and check that
and create alerts based on that as well.
Yes?
- First of all,
you mentioned tags.
So can we use the tags
to identify the server
that needs an update?
We're bringing the tags, if I say,
"Hey, this is my server
that needs this new update."
- [Pravin] So that is a little,
fundamentally there is
no way based on tag,
or EC2 instance for us to identify
what certificate is on that server.
Unless you create an
application that actually
goes and does a grep
across different folders
and identifies the certificates on there.
There is no easy way to identify
what sort is installed in
which server without knowing
who put it there or where it is,
there are solutions,
third party solutions that try to do it.
The other way I've seen
people do it is they identify
the endpoint and try to do a TLS
and get the certificate
information based on that.
- [Crowd Member 6] Do
you recommend a agent
where you install that and
have the agent run that,
is it possible?
- [Pravin] Possible, so yeah.
So you and the agent will
actually have to do a grep,
or something across the disk
to identify those certificate that is,
what certificates are
already stored on that.
So this solution doesn't do that.
It only takes the cert,
it takes the exportable
certificate, installs it on EC2
and then it also renews it
for you at the end of it.
So, all right.
- [Crowd Member 6] This
just the concept you did?
(speaks in distance)
- [Pravin] Sorry, say that again.
- [Crowd Member 6] This is
like a cool concept you did,
it's not AWS?
- [Zach] That's right, yeah.
This is something that, yeah, we built,
published on GitHub as a
sample code for customers.
Yeah, that's right.
So affordable certs feature,
of course, is a feature that
the ACM service team built.
But what Pravin's showing
today is something
that we built and to the point
about certificate inventory,
I would agree with Pravin that
I typically see customers use
partner solutions maybe
familiar with Venafi,
or AppViewX to go out
and discover where
certificates are placed.
And as far as ACME, today,
ACM does not support ACME.
Let's talk after and we
can talk about Roadmap.
But today ACME is not supported by ACM.
- [Crew Member] Please, please, ladies,
please.
- Yep. (laughs)
We're being recorded.
So I can't really talk about Roadmap,
but we here, we're a
customer-obsessed company.
Many, many customers have asked for ACME
and you can infer what you will from that.
- [Pravin] Yeah,
so the next part is a CrossAccount,
like some of the questions
over here, how does it work,
CrossAccount.
So yes, this solution
does work CrossAccount,
you have a cloud formation template,
there are a couple of cloud
formation templates in here.
One is to do the central
account implementation,
which is all your step function
and everything is in one
account from where you want
to issue your certificates and stuff.
And then you just create some
IAM roles for CrossAccount
so that your systems manager is able to go
and run commands on your EC2 instances
and then also your EC2 instances
once created are able to go
and access those secrets that
are creating in that account.
So what is the important thing
here is the passphrase is
actually stored in the
same account as where
the EC2 instances it is.
So we don't want, I didn't
want the EC2 instance
to go back and get secrets
from another account.
So that's why we kind of cleaned
up the solution to do that.
So that's the solution.
All right.
Yeah, so that's the link
for the GitHub code.
So if you scan it or if you just look for
sample-acm-export-certificate-automation
in AWS samples,
you will find the solution.
It has a very detailed
read me, it talks about how
to do the installation,
how to test out the
installation and everything.
It's very detailed and if
you still have any issues,
feel free to add and comment
or something on there,
or just reach out to me based on the email
that will be shared at the end.
All right, so now I'll switch,
I'll switch to the demo mode
to show exactly what we
are doing and before that,
oh yeah, thanks.
This is Kiro, so I build
this solution in Kiro.
I know Kiro is something
everybody's talking about today.
If you haven't tried
Kiro, definitely try it.
It's based on VSCode,
but it's still, it's pretty useful.
So the template that
you're seeing over there
is the template for calling the API.
So like I said, it takes the
certificate ARN, it takes,
you can give it a name and then you can,
you have to give the
target the tag values,
which is env and dev is the
tag value that I'm using
and the target account, so the
account where you want to go
and install the certificate as well.
So you could do, you
have to give these values
and this will trigger the step function.
So I'm gonna sit down and
do the demo.
If you have any questions or
anything, raise your hands
and let me know.
The API gateway is actually
IAM-protected.
So who calls the API?
The person has to be or
has to have the right,
or valid IAM role to
actually invoke the API.
So that's a security, it's
not like anybody can export
the certificate and put
it on any EC2 instance.
So we have added a layer of IAM as well.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to use AWS curl command,
which basically takes my IAM profile,
which is on my desktop and
uses it to call directly
instead of me passing the SDS
tokens through curl command.
So that, you can see the execution ID.
I'm gonna come here.
So that started the execution of my code.
So first is the export cert.
We have the input
of the certificate ARN on all the details.
What it did is actually it
exported the certificate
and it also did is it added
the secret in the secret.
And this is the whole
encrypted public private key
that you're seeing out here.
And this details is now,
so if you see the certificate
name is Demo December 2,
after that it,
after creating everything
in the Secrets Manager
and stuff, it's gonna call this,
it's going to call the Systems Manager
for the automation document.
So I'm passing all the certificate details
to the Systems Manager, I'm sorry.
And
it's gonna execute and it's gonna,
if you see here there is
an automation execution ID,
that means that the execution has started,
the automation execution has started.
This is a CrossAccount deployment.
I am on account starting with 70
and this is gonna install
on another account,
which starts with 090.
So you could see that it's
going to do a CrossAccount.
- [Zach] Okay, perfect, yeah.
So we do have examples of
CrossAccount there, great.
- [Pravin] Yeah, so
lot of times the automation
takes some time if you are
installing on multiple
EC2 instances across,
so that is a wait section
on that, it basically waits
for the automation document
to complete successfully.
And once it has the
automation status completed,
it just moved to success
rates based on the number
of EC2 instances.
If it fails to install on
any one EC2 instance also,
it will generate an error
and you'll have to go back
and see in the Systems Manager as to what
exactly happened there.
So this code is going to do all that.
So this is the DynamoDB table
and I told you that it's
gonna have all the details
of the certificate.
So it has a key, a primary key,
it has the certificate ARN,
it has the certificates expiry date.
It also has the certificate
name that you gave.
So in this case we did a
December 2, so that's the one.
It has the details of where
the passphrase is stored
of your Secrets Manager,
where the passphrase is stored
and which target account that
certificate is installed.
Even that detail is
available in the database.
So if you want to check
anything, what's going on,
you can do that from here.
Any questions until now?
So I'm going to the other account-
- [Zach] Right, question there.
- [Pravin] Yes.
- [Crowd Member 7] This solution,
is it expandable to
EC2's clusters as well,
or (speaks in the distance).
- [Pravin] That's a good question.
I actually was trying to
do that whereas I got,
I didn't get any customer
feedback on people wanting
to go on EC2 clusters.
But if it's an EC2 instance
and you can run an
automation document on it,
you will be able to install
it anywhere over there.
Should not be an issue.
- [Zach] The code as it
exists today doesn't have
run documents like
Pravin mentioned for ECS
but there's no reason
you wouldn't be able to,
that's good feedback and
I think we can adjust it
to include that because yeah,
you'll definitely be able
to put that private key on an ECS task,
but we haven't built
that into the solution
as of right now, yeah.
- [Pravin] Yep.
- [Crowd Member 7] You have
a customer service mesh,
(speaks in the distance)
- [Pravin] Have a customer
service solution for what?
I'm sorry.
- Service mesh.
- [Pravin] Service mesh, no,
I don't think we did that, right?
- [Zach] No, so you mean for
the MTLS between services?
Yeah, so really public certificates,
which is what we're talking about today,
you can no longer really
use them for MTLS,
because you might be aware
another cab forum changed recently was
that public certificates
are no longer allowed
to have what's called the
client auth extended key usage,
which is necessary for MTM MTLS.
So this particular kind of solution
and public certificates
would not work there.
I mentioned a service
AWS private CA earlier,
that you can absolutely
issue private certificates
of any template and as long as it's X509,
you can adjust that
template however you'd like.
And so we do have customers
that use that for service
to service communication.
There was a service called
AWS App Mesh that would,
sometimes customers would use for that.
I more commonly see customers
use partner solutions
like SDO today.
So yes, but you would not
necessarily be doing that
with these public certs, as
you're not able to anymore.
That would be something you
would look at private certs
with AWS Private CA or Windows
PKI or something like that.
Anytime you're using a private cert,
that's where you would do that.
MTLS between services for example.
- [Pravin] So this is the EC2 instance.
It has the tag, env and dev,
so it's going to go, it went
and installed it on this one.
This is the instance profile
of that EC2 instance.
Basically what IAM rules
that EC2 instance has,
and if you see this is the
IAM policy that was added
to the EC2 instances, which
is using tag-based access
to actually go and access
the secret that is created
by the automation at this point.
So if you go ahead
and check for the secrets over here,
you will see that it has created a secret.
Right now this is a new brand
new secret created which has
the passphrase and it also
has the tags attached to it.
So basically what it did is
it went to the other account,
it installed the certificate
and I can show the certificates
that are installed over here
and this is exactly what I
didn't want to happen. (laughs)
So it logged me out.
All right, and we can actually
go and check the certificate.
So I have commands ready on that.
So right now it is installing
the certificates on EC2 SSL
certs doc folder in this Linux machine.
So if I run the grep, if you can see
those two certificate, so this
is the public certificate,
so it has the full
chain of the certificate
and the certificate as well in there.
And then the private key
actually goes in another folder,
which is SSL private.
Over here and that's the
private key that is installed
in that server, which is CrossAccount.
Now to access that certificate,
I have a small script
which will actually extract
the passphrase from the Secrets Manager
and I can use that passphrase now
to actually decrypt the private key,
which is that, so a lot of
times some applications ask
for private key unencrypted,
or some ask for private
key with a passphrase
inside the applications,
or depending on how
you want it, you could,
your EC2 instance now has access
to retrieve the passphrase
and do the changes on that part.
So that's the CrossAccount part.
So this is the part one of the
solution where you created,
you exported a certificate
and installed it on an EC2 instance.
Now, the part two of the
solution is the EventBridge part.
So when you install this
cloud formation template,
this service actually
installs a EventBridge rule,
which actually looks
for a specific pattern.
Now, I modified it.
If you look at the source
over here it says test,
but when you actually run
the cloud formation template,
it will be ACM service.
Now, why I did that,
because I want to
manually invoke this event
to show the flow,
but when you actually
do it, you don't need to run it manually
for testing purposes.
As soon as the ACM generates
the event, your flow should be,
will be kicked off, in my case,
for it to renew and do the
step, it takes a few minutes
and so it's not good for demo purposes,
but that's why I changed
the source to test.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to trigger this event
and this event is actually
going to go and trigger
a step function.
So let's look at that.
So there is command on how
to trigger this event as
well inside the code sample
that I showed you that is there.
So let's run this
from here.
There you go.
So that should have triggered an execution
over here.
Let's see.
So
it's running three execution,
because the ARN of that
certificate is attached
to three different EC2 entries.
So it's going to renew
it in all three places
in the database.
So that's why you're
seeing three instances.
But what it's doing now is it's actually
doing the same steps.
It got the details from the
DynamoDB table as to whether
that, all these certificate
is being referenced.
And then from there it's
actually taking it and moving it
and taking those details and
going and installing it as is.
So this is basically hands off
just like application
load balancer CloudFront.
Once you install the certificate with ACM,
you just forget about it,
it renews on it's own.
Similarly with the EC2 instance,
this solution can renew
on it's own as well.
So that's how this would work.
Any questions on any of this point?
Yes.
- [Crowd Member 8] So
the only prerequisite
for this to work is to make
the certificate export?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Is it because we have a few
certificates that are told
also you can enable AWS and
don't require load balancers,
so this would work fine
for the on-prem load balancers
certificate if you export-
- [Pravin] Yeah, so if you have services
that are already integrated with ACM,
like application load balancer,
CloudFront, API Gateway,
et cetera, for those services,
you don't have to worry about it.
It'll just, yeah, it
does it out of the box.
The problem comes when
you export the certificate
and move it on,
I have customers who are also
trying to use this solution
to export the certificate
and put it on a S3 bucket,
or somewhere for a third party team
to pick up the certificate
and install it on some
custom solutions as well,
because they don't want
to do the automation to go
and do install it
directly inside somewhere,
because they have a
very specific use case.
All they want is a self-service
where somebody requests the certificate
and go, you could actually
modify the IAM rules
and policies as well
and the lambda function to
allow specific teams to only
request specific certificates
based on their tag,
or naming conventions as well.
So you could add that customization
in the Lambda function side as well.
So if you have those kind of requirement,
you could do the modification,
or if you need any help around
that, if there are a lot
of requests coming and saying,
"Hey, I want to see that."
You could do that because I
was playing around with that
and yes, you could actually
do a little bit more
fine grain access control
on how the certificates are made.
- [Zach] Yeah, it uses IAM condition keys.
So you would basically
write a policy that says,
"Only app team A can request certificates
with the domain name example.com
and app team B can request
certificates with food.com,
but not example.com."
So you can create condition
keys like that in IAM policy,
or SCPs, for example,
or service control policies
to limit that as well
as things like key type,
like RSA versus ECC and things like that.
So you can get fine grain
for those permissions.
And to your point about
like having the certificate
on a managed service as well as on-prem,
even if the certificate is marked
as exportable, managed renewal
with integrated services
still works the same way.
So it would still be renewed
in the same way on, say,
your application load balancer
and then you would also get a notification
through EventBridge that,
"Hey, a new certificate
is available for export."
And you could either manually export,
or use a solution like this
to grab it automatically.
- [Crowd Member 1] Through
that granular control
that you were just talking about,
would it be possible to
restrict requests for wildcards
to still allow the route naming convention
but this, so any FQDN at the
sub-domain level is fine,
but not the wildcard.
- [Zach] Yes, yes.
You can specifically restrict wildcards
from being issued, 'cause
some customers say,
"I don't want my developers
to ever issue wildcards."
Yes, you can absolutely do that.
- [Pravin] Yeah, all right,
switch it to presentation.
- [Zach] Sure.
Yeah, so let me kind of wrap up here
and then again, if folks
have other questions,
feel free to ask.
We have about nine minutes left and then
after that we'll be out in
the hallway if you wanna
talk more, particularly
about Roadmap stuff,
we can absolutely talk
a little bit about that
in the hallway.
So yeah, just key
takeaways that we want you
to remember after this session, obviously,
we want you to think about this
new feature from ACM,
exportable public certificates.
Think about how you're
gonna manage renewals
for certificates that you
export the private key for,
whether it's something like this,
or a more manual process,
obviously we want you
to get to this place of
automation when you can,
but it is becoming more
and more important like we talked about
with those cab forum changes.
Someone pointed out, I think
in March it's going down
to 180 days and then I
believe by 2029, it's 47 days.
So, for customers that
are doing this manually,
if you have hundreds of
certificates that you have
to renew manually every single,
about every month or so,
a month and a half, that's
not super sustainable.
And so even if you're not doing all this
through automation today,
we're definitely encouraging customers
to start moving more
towards automated solutions
for replacing these certificates.
And then the other thing would be,
when we're looking at, when
you look at that sample code,
we just want to keep in mind
that you want to protect that passphrase
of that private key 'cause
that's how it's encrypted
and you want to kind of limit the risk of
that public key being put
accidentally somewhere
and then being able to be decrypted.
Like blog somewhere in your application,
or accidentally put on
GitHub or something.
And so you want to protect
that with a passphrase
and store that passphrase
in a very secure place.
And that's why when Pravin
and I built this sample code,
we put it in Secrets Manager
and we specifically generated
it through, there's a API
in Secrets Manager called
Get Random Password
or yeah, I think it's Get Random Password.
And so no human being sees that secret,
it's put in Secrets Manager
and even your developers
and whatnot shouldn't
be able to access that.
It's just the automated
service can access it.
And then I think like another piece is
we designed it with the tag-based approach
just because that makes it
easier to understand, again,
where are these certificates placed,
which EC2 instances have which certificate
and through those tags
and that DynamoDB table that
Pravin mentioned and showed.
That's kind of how we're looking at that.
And then last thing would be, of course,
with the question around ECS,
there are gonna be some
customizations for this
and this is just like
we mentioned earlier,
kind of a POC sample code we built.
So definitely feel free
to reach out to Pravin
and I or contribute
back to the GitHub code
and make our life easier
if you wanna do it for us.
But we're happy to do it
as well if you have specific things you
wanna see added to this.
So just let us know.
- [Pravin] Also, just to add to it, Zach,
so if you have, is
anybody over here looking
to actually use ACM certificate outside
AWS environment,
like on a third party cloud
provider and stuff like that?
- [Crowd Member 2] On-prem.
- On-prem.
- On-prem is fine.
On-prem, yes.
What about out-
- Azure?
Yeah, so I'm actually working on something
where it moves it to the vault over there
that is recently some new
IAM method that has come out
where you could actually
generate JW tokens authenticate
to a third party and put stuff in there.
So I'm trying to work on that,
but that's something we can
talk about after the survey.
- [Crowd Member 9] We were in a position
where our show VMs are managed by SSM.
- So you say-
- In that case,
I don't know that we've tested that,
but I believe that should work.
If they have VMs in another cloud provider
that are managed by SSM, that should-
- [Pravin] Yeah, if you have an-
- [Crowd Member 9] Write a
motivation against it then,
from SSM, which is
(speaks in the distance).
- [Pravin] So the way SSM works is as long
as there is an agent running there
and it's connectivity back
is there, it should work.
That's how on-prem works.
So I don't see why it wouldn't work on
any other cloud provider.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
- [Zach] Yeah, as long
as the agent's installed
and it has a network path
and access to the API and whatnot,
yeah, absolutely should.
Okay, any other questions or
anything before we wrap up?
Happy to answer anything.
- [Pravin] There's one.
- [Crowd Member 3] Is
there a link or something
to your code that you're running?
- [Zach] Yeah, will
you throw that back up?
- [Pravin] Should I just
go to the next slide?
- [Zach] Oh yes, thank you.
Yeah, right there.
Yeah, you can grab that.
Or I think if you search AWS samples,
export cert automation,
it should come up as well.
But yeah, that's the GitHub link there.
- [Pravin] Yeah, even if
you look up, do a ChatGPT,
it actually brings up that
solution, I've seen it.
- [Zach] Okay, cool.
- [Pravin] (laughs) How do you
automate certificates in AWS,
and one of the solution, is that one.
- [Zach] I did not know that, that's neat.
All right.
Okay, any other questions?
Awesome, well, I appreciate
your time, thank you very much.
And feel free to find us in the hallway
if you have other questions.
Wanna talk through anything, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.